after an extra challenging year ccsd
seniors are dining their caps and gowns
ready to take on the world
high schools across the district holding
in-person graduations after more than a
year of online learning
sasha loftis extended and attended an
extra special event this evening joining
us live now from thomas and mack
with a bit more on those graduates sasha
brian those we spoke with today here at
the thomas and mack center were just
really happy to celebrate in person
after a year of so much distance and
difficulty
now as for ccsd faculty and staff they
wanted to make today
extra special as they send those
students off into the world
we are not the forgotten class with pomp
and circumstance
and a whole lot of pride
these high school seniors took the stage
to graduate
it's not what we imagined our senior
year to look like
but we made the best out of it any
ceremony is special
but advanced technologies academy
principal jonathan seinolds says
this was even more memorable thank you
all for sharing this honorable
celebration
as 250 students reunited at unlv's
thomas and mack center wednesday
after 14 months of online learning they
all
rose to the occasion they understood the
circumstances and they
realized that online learning can
continue and it did continue
and they're ready for college the kovit
19 pandemic has turned
things upside down for so many so much
confusion and
[Music]
it was a hassle basically but like we
got through it so i'm proud of us
but the struggles each family here faced
help them truly appreciate this moment
we're here
we didn't it you know and know that
after this they are ready to face
anything the future brings it was
definitely a long haul the last year
so i'm super excited to be finished on
to the next chapter
this actually was the first live event
to be held here at
the thomas and mack center since march
of last year this was actually the first
time this particular ccst high school
held a graduation ceremony at a venue
that was this large
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now